are you on threads yeah dude I got a
thread yeah cool man the conversation
surrounding threats is Zuck is winning
Zuck is beating musk Zuck vs musk Zuck
win round one of new Twitter game Who
Elon Musk uh yeah Elon Musk losing to
Zuck and now people are championing Zach
there's a lot of like uh memes that
should have sucked that are like oh we
love Zack now it's like are people not
remembering right before threads
everybody hated Zuck everybody
hated meta everybody hated they changed
the name everybody hates the
Oculus he's another billionaire
but now people love him now he's cute
again all you gotta do is make a threads